das frauengefängnis mosley erdogan und
andere opponenten einsetzen wie ein
symbol für den widerstand der türkischen
zivilgesellschaft hat sich hier die
mahnwache festgesetzt
heute ist vieles caracciolo zu besuch
die prominente parlamentarier in der hdp
der einzigen noch nicht verbotenen
kurdenpartei heute können alle
journalisten schriftsteller studenten
schüler lehrkräfte und andere beamte
sogar bürgermeister akademiker aber auch
arbeiter alle können des terrors
angeklagt werden wir alle jederzeit die
aktuelle regierung fährt wieder den
altbekannten kurs es geht darum den
kurdenkonflikt zu schüren und den
faschismus zu stärken
wir sind wieder an dem selben punkt das
wichtigste ziel ist es die kurdische
bevölkerung mundtot zu machen und ihre
bedürfnisse zu unterdrücken
ohne eine zivilisierte annäherung wird
niemals ein frieden erreicht werden
können
leider wird auch wieder gefoltert in der
türkei während all das geschieht wird
aber gar nicht aufgeklärt welche
politischen hintergrund der
putschversuch wirklich hatte und wer
alles dabei war
stattdessen wird ständig alles vertuscht
und im ausnahmezustand gelingt es
natürlich besonders gut
die kurdische politikerin weiß was
hinter dieser systematischen
unterdrückung steckt die strategie
besteht darin immer mehr führungsmacht
zu erlangen
die kompetenzen zentral zu stärken so
dass die regierung ohne laute opposition
agieren kann
dabei geht es der führung auch darum
ihre eigene korruption und ihre eigenen
verbrechen zu vertuschen
wenn es in diesem land die demokratie
gebe
mit einer unabhängigen justiz dann würde
man die regierenden alle vor gericht
stellen
deswegen diese unterdrückung strategie
das kranken beobachten ich glaube dass
die machthaber sich vor bestrafung
fürchten deswegen gehen sie ja so
aggressiv vor und mit jedem mal
aggressiver